- I have always been
amazed with how well Rachel
cries and talks at the
same time in movies.
(Rachel laughing)
This is not a joke.
(audience laughing)
- [Abby] (indistinct)
- I'm not just saying this right now.
I, just on this show alone, we have proof,
but I've said it many a times in life.
Here's the tape.
(wind whooshing)
I wish I could like Rachel
McAdams cry from the Notebook,
but it's just not in the cards.
- It's not reality.
(audience laughing)
It's not.
- That's not real.
I just need a minute.
I'm so sorry. I can't talk when I cry.
I'm not Rachel McAdams. (sniffling)
(everyone laughing)
I can't, I can't.
- [Henry] You look good.
- Yeah.
- Nothing is dripping.
- Not everyone looks great crying.
- You don't look like Giuliani at all.
(Kelly laughing)
- I also don't look like Rachel
McAdams from The Notebook,
so I'm trying to handle it.
(audience laughing)
(wind whooshing)
- I'm not kidding.
(audience cheering)
I say it all the time.
- (laughing) Oh my god.
- Because you know what it is?
I'm angry about it. (laughing)
Like, I don't understand how you do that.
(Rachel laughing)
Like, you have this thing where you cry
and still look beautiful and it's gross.
(everyone laughing)
It's like what?
- It's so disgusting.
- Like your ugly cry is still
unbelievably cute and sexy.
I don't get it.
(Rachel laughing)
- What are you, why?
Like how do you do that?
How do you hold your face together?
- I practice
(Kelly laughing)
in front of the mirror.
- Okay.
- For a really long time.
- No, I'm teaching a masterclass in-
- [Kelly] Crying.
- Pretty crying.
I don't know.
I don't feel like it is pretty, but-
- Oh my God.
- And I think you look gorgeous.
- It's adorable.
You're lying. And I love you for it.
(audience laughing)
It's just one of those things
I was like, oh my gosh,
she comes on here, we
have to talk about this.
It's literally, I say it everywhere.
- [Rachel] That's so funny.
- Because it's one of those
things I feel like is rare.
Even like the greatest
actors think about movie.
You're like, not everybody
looks great crying.
- But if you grew up watching
Demi Moore in Ghosts.
- Oh, I did.
- You know, that tear where
nothing else is moving
like the ac-, you know,
that's an actress's like,
oh, if I could get that to Mecca.
- Don't worry. You're there.
(audience lightly laughing)
Yeah. It's upsetting to the rest of us.
(Rachel laughing)
It's like, wait, I look like a hot mess.
Like, is she all right?
Like that's how I look, anyway.